I'm Muslim, but I don't believe in
trying to convert anybody. I believe
only God converts people. I really just
need some understanding on like what
points are you trying to connect with
Jesus? Because I feel like us as
Muslims, we don't have any disconnect
with Jesus. There's no issue of Jesus is
pure, Jesus is the Messiah, Jesus is the
one who's untouched, Jesus is the one
whose blood is of light to us, but that
doesn't mean that we worship him. I
don't believe that because you're
Christian, I'm not going to see my
fellow Christian brothers in heaven. I
don't know why everybody believes
Muslims are this The Quran
The Quran says
>> Yeah, but again, the Bible says a lot of
things that we take out of context.
>> let me respond to you now. So, the
reason why we understand that according
to Islam, Jews and Christians will not
be in heaven with you Muslims according
to your theology is because the Quran
literally says in chapter 98 verse 6, it
says, "Those who disbelieve among the
Jews and the Christians and the
polytheists will have their abode in
hellfire. They are the worst of
creatures." So, the Quran is clear when
it comes to my condition or my
destination as a Christian who rejects
Islam. I reject
>> a Muslim who accepts Islam and reads
that for themselves, not through the
eyes of other people, not through their
friends' eyes, through the people that
they see and they follow, who accepts
and listens to this verse for
themselves, me as a Muslim, I believe
that means if you truly in your heart
are a disbeliever, not in your mind
again, Allah tells us that he's put
people in instances where they
whispered, "I am a true believer." Just
because they didn't want to be cast in
stone. So, I'm not going to say that
because you whispered that you're not a
true believer, you're not a true
believer cuz only God knows your intent.
So, if you are not a true believer, I do
not believe that you will be in heaven
with the true believer. That does not
mean that I don't believe in Jesus. That
doesn't mean that I don't believe in
Moses. That doesn't mean I believe in
Abraham. No, to you it does. But Allah
says Wait, wait wait one second. We pay
for our own sins, though. Yeah, let me
let me You asked where we was coming
from. Where I'm coming from, that shows
your disconnect. When you say that Jesus
is the Messiah, for example, what does
that mean?
Jesus is the one that walked this earth,
the most purest form of human beings.
But that's not what that
>> pure form. So, again, That's true, but
that's not what that means. That's not
what Messiah means.
So, what do you interpret that that
means? Okay.
>> The actual definition, so I can gain
some more clarity. All right. The actual
word means anointed one. He's the
anointed
>> Okay. So, the the one that walks One
second. The one that walks this earth
with no sin
You're trying to get
me off track. No, I'm just I just want
to say I just want to ask you this. So,
the person that walks amongst this earth
with no sin, the most purest form, is
not the anointed one? He's the anointed
one, but it does The Messiah, the word
Messiah doesn't mean one who is
absolutely pure and walks this earth
who's the, you know, purest and cleanest
of us all. That's not what that means.
The word Messiah means anointed one, and
he's anointed for a specific purpose, to
do something. He's supposed to do
something. Do you know what the Messiah
was supposed to do? To spread the word
of God, the true word of God. Nope. So,
what was he Well, that's what our
intentions is as Muslims. So, as a
Christian, what is the true We're not
talking about your intention as a
Muslim. I'm talking about the purpose of
the Messiah. What was the Messiah
supposed to do? What was his mission,
you know?
To gather the true believers. As a
Muslim, I would believe to gather the
true believers that were in disbelief,
people that weren't believing.
>> Nope. Your your The Quran doesn't even
say that. Here's the Here's the point.
The Quran is silent about why Jesus is
identified as the Messiah. It's silent.
It doesn't tell you why.
It just assumes that he's the Messiah
because, yes, it's true, he is, but it
doesn't break down why. It doesn't show
how he accomplished that or how he
fulfilled that mission as the Messiah.
It doesn't tell you. This is the
disconnect. Where you need to So, now,
when you have this disconnect about
Jesus as the Messiah, you then now have
false beliefs about Jesus. This is where
>> You assume that you have false beliefs
because
I don't have false beliefs about Jesus.
I know there was a purpose for him.
There was a time where he was needed. He
came from the
purest Virgin Mary who who was never
touched and she beholder the child. So,
there was signs that God was sending for
Jesus because he knew that we were
living in wicked times. We needed this
pureness. Okay.
>> need somebody to walk and talk like us
and act like us and sin like us.
>> did his What does his pureness do for
me? Because it says that he was in the
Quran it says this. Chapter 19 verse
>> the message. But not just that though
cuz
what message though?
What message specifically was Jesus
spreading?
>> There is one God. You must not kill. You
must not
>> Everybody knew that already.
Jews knew that already. They already had
the law.
>> And we still were going through chaos
and you see what happened with the Jews.
They destroyed the world like [laughter]
Why do you think prophets are being
sent? They're being sent for the time
that they're needed. But are they are
they being are they being sent to say
the exact same thing over and over? If
it correlates with one God, you should
repeat the same thing over. We believe
that only one God sent that message and
we all should correlate.
>> Wait. So, were the Jews were the Jews
worshipping multiple gods when Jesus
showed up? No, but the Jews were living
in an in an astonishing way. You know
the stories of the Jews and this is even
in the Quran.
>> look look here's the point though. The
point is is that the Jews were already
monotheistic. They already worshipped
one God. So, if they were already
worshipped one God, they didn't need
anyone to tell them there's only one
God. They already knew that. What was
the message that Jesus came for them
then? They were falling out of the
realms. They were living in devilish
ways. They were living letting the
shaitan the devil get to them. Although
you believe in one God, that doesn't
mean you won't be tested. That won't
That doesn't mean that he's not going to
send hardship at your ways for you to
fight it.
>> Jesus say? I got you. What did Jesus say
is the way to get to get right with God.
What did he say?
So as far as Christianity, I'm not
exactly sure, but I believe that in
Islam is to believe in one God and if
you do sin
>> No, I'm I'm continuing and if you sin
repent for your sins every time that you
go out and live this life. If you make a
bad deed
Where does the Quran tell you that Jesus
taught to to repent of your sins? Where
does Where does the Quran say that?
>> He He had no sin.
No, no, no. Where Where does the Quran
He was telling you to walk in my life.
He's telling you to walk like me and he
is of no sin that means that you should
not commit sin.
>> Show me in the Quran.
>> us don't He tells us don't backbite.
Okay, where does Where in the Quran does
Jesus say don't backbite? Jesus, I don't
I don't know the exact verse in there
where he states that Jesus doesn't say
backbite. It's not Here's my point,
sister. My point is is that
>> you think that we're going to know So do
you believe Listen.
The Quran doesn't tell you what Jesus
taught. That's the point. That's the
disconnect. The Quran doesn't tell you
what Jesus taught or why he specifically
came. So is that the premises of of
Islam not being real because they don't
go into full depth of what Jesus taught?
>> No, that's not why. Here's Here's the
Here's This is why.
So because there's a disconnect, because
it doesn't tell you what Jesus taught it
gets wrong the things that Jesus
believed in and and these things about
him.
>> What did I say in this conversation that
was wrong? What did I say in this
conversation that I got from Jesus that
was wrong? So for example, cuz
when you're saying that he came to
get them back right with God
you don't have an answer of what did he
say is the way to get back to get right
with God. What Jesus said was when we
read the Gospel, we can see what he
said. He said, "Come to me.
Come to me. Whoever believes in me, he
will never thirst nor will he hunger.
You come to me, I will give you rest.
You come to me and believe in me, you
will have everlasting life. You come to
me
>> believe that when people come to Jesus,
their intent is not pure? You believe
that everybody that came to Jesus was
pure intent? Do you believe that? No, I
don't. The ones who The ones who come
and believe in him, those are the ones
who are saved and made right with God.
The ones who are hypocrites and reject
him
and don't believe what he says about
himself, they are still
you know, stained with their sin. This
is why I'm saying this about Islam. So
you're saying that about Islam?
>> you don't you don't know Christ. That
Jesus
>> [laughter]
>> We don't what? You don't know Christ as
a Muslim.
>> what, Satan?
You don't you don't know Christ.
>> I'm not Listen, listen, listen. You're
I've never said on here and said I know
Christ. That I didn't say I know
Christ's book from the beginning to the
end. But what I gathered throughout my
reading, again, we all have to sit here
and remember that we're not going to pay
for anybody else's reading. We're not
going to pay for anybody else's sins.
We're not going to pay for anybody
else's wrongdoings, only ourselves. So
when I read, I have to make sure it
resonates with myself cuz you can tell
me anything. You can tell me anything
you want about Christ, but it might not
resonate with me the way it resonates
with you. That doesn't make me a
disbeliever in Christ. Doesn't doesn't
matter who it resonates with. It's It's
what God
>> it's supposed to because if you're if
you're saying you believe in Jesus and
it really is not in your heart that you
believe in Jesus, that's the problem.
Let me respond.
It doesn't matter whether you agree with
what Jesus said or or disagree with what
he said.
What he said is what he said.
>> hear what I said. You didn't hear what I
said. I said you can say you can agree.
I said listen. I said you can say you
agree with them, but in your heart it
doesn't resonate.
So we're remembering that God believes
in your intentions of your heart, not
what you say. what you
>> if if if his words don't resonate with
you, then you
>> them people that they are Christian?
That doesn't mean you're really
Christian. That doesn't mean
>> There's the disconnect. Pay attention.
There's the disconnect. If you're saying
that his words don't resonate with you,
No, I never said that. Listen, listen,
listen. You got to listen to what I'm
saying. There are people who wear a mask
on their face and they tell people that
they are believers. They believe in
Christ and in their heart they truly do
not. Who are you to tell them that they
are a true believer? Who am I to tell
them that they are a true believer? We
do not know that. Yes, we do. You know
them by their fruits. The Bible Jesus
says this, this is how you know the ones
who follow me. You know them by their
fruits. The ones who bear the fruit of
Christ, bear the fruit of the Holy
Spirit, And in 2024 and in 2024, what is
that fruit? I'm I'm I'm talking here. I
just want to know what's that fruit in
2024.
>> me off, bro. Come on, Jazz. I just let
you talk.
>> not your bro. I just let you talk. Okay.
So, you got to if I'm going to give you
respect, you got to have the same
respect back. All right? Yes. So, when
you have Jesus saying, "Those who bear
my fruits,
those are the ones who are in me."
We We see this now. We can tell who's a
true who's a believer or not
or example, Jesus teaches that he is the
son of God who came to give his life for
the sins of the world. Do you believe
that?
I believe that he is a product of God
and he came here to reveal God's
message. So, do you believe that he's
the son of God that came to give his
life for your sins?
I believe he is the son of God that came
to give us a message to clear us from
our sins. I don't believe that
I believe we all are the children of
God. I believe he is a special son. Yes,
most definitely. Well, your Quran says
no. Your Quran says neither Jesus is the
son of God nor are you a daughter of
Allah.
So if we want to state that we are all
children of God, I mean that in the
aspect we are all God's creations. We
are not created without God. You're
stating that it doesn't specifically say
I am the son or I am the daughter of
God. I do not need that to know that in
my heart.
>> Listen, chapter 19 verse 93.
None can come to Allah except as a
slave. You cannot come to him as a
daughter or a son. You could only come
to him as a slave. He's only your
master.
>> of God. He's He is my master. He's a
slave I am a slave of God.
>> So So your Quran contradicts what you
said cuz you said you believe Jesus is a
special son of God, which I agree with,
but your Quran rejects that.
>> So a special creation. I don't need the
Quran to specifically say
I am a son of God to believe that I am a
creation of God because without God I am
not created, correct?
>> still affirm that Jesus is the son of
God? Do you still affirm that or no?
Yes, I believe we are all children of
God. So then you reject the Quran.
So then
you reject the Quran.
>> No, I don't. You want me to reject the
Quran. I don't reject the Quran because
it doesn't specifically say that. What
What type of Let me Let me show you
Let me show you Let me just show you how
you reject the Quran. Let me just show
you.
>> No, you can't show me anything.
You can't show me anything.
>> Yeah, I can. I'mma show you right now.
I'mma show you.
>> You're going to show me what you
interpret. That's what you're going to
do. You can say that. I'm going to show
you I'mma let you read.
I'mma let you read.
I'mma let you read. No, you read it.
It's your show. It's your platform.
Here you go.
Cuz I don't want you saying that I
misinterpreted or anything like that. Go
ahead and can you read this one?
>> is this? You asking me what is this?
Chapter 9 verse 30 of the Quran.
So I can't pull my Quran in cuz I'm on
my phone and I I don't I just learned
how to do this live stuff, so I have the
Quran up for you. Yeah, but there's
there's multiple translations. So, let's
not let's not
>> What what translation do you want?
Read it and interpret it how you want me
to understand.
>> interpreting anything. I want you to
read it. I don't want you to accuse me
of
saying, "Oh, you're interpreting it in
your own way." Can you read it so that
there's no confusion? You read it for
me, sir. I'm not here to read anything.
I'm here to explain and express my
feelings after that that you state. So,
you go ahead and read it.
>> We're here about truth, not feelings.
>> Okay, truth. I'm here to state my peace.
How about that? I'm here to state my
peace.
>> it says, "The Christians say, the
Messiah is the son of Allah."
That is their statement from their
mouths. They imitate those
uh those saying of those who disbelieve.
May Allah destroy them. How deluded are
they?
So, Allah the Quran says that you're
deluded and a disbeliever for saying
Jesus is the son of God.
Okay, so can we take in effect that when
this was revealed, people were rejecting
Islam because it came from the prophet.
So, can we reject can we say that he's
stating that in the sense of you're
rejecting my word because of who it's
coming out of. You're killing the
message because of the messenger.
>> is
predicting Jesus who says he's the son
of God. Muhammad just said it in the
Quran, but not
>> It says the Christians say the
Christians say
>> with the Quran verse? So, these
Christians could be disbelievers. Do we
not know that? We don't know what
disbelievers
>> Why are they disbelievers?
According to the verse, what what makes
them a disbeliever?
The way they're stating that he's the
son of God directly lineage.
>> so you just said that Jesus is the son
of God. So, you're a disbeliever
according to the Quran.
So, don't you guys don't you don't you
Christians believe that Jesus is God?
Don't you No, no, no, no. Don't try to
change the subject. No, I'm not trying
to change the subject. I'm trying to get
a clarity.
I'm trying to You You can't even let me
go in character. Boot me. Do what you do
best. Yeah, take care of yourself.
Can't even follow a conversation. It
doesn't matter if they're male or female
on this in this religion.
All of them are half-brained.